today's episode of lunch money is
brought to you by ftx us if you go into
the link in the description you can sign
up for ftx why the hell would you do
that well here's a real good reason they
have some of the best pricing most
competitive pricing in the entire market
these guys they know what they're doing
they are experts at building
infrastructure they've got one of the
largest international exchanges and
they're coming to the us and they aren't
playing around obviously they got ftx
arena here in miami on top of that
they're not just going to be doing
crypto if you want best pricing go and
check out ftx us but
on top of that if you want access to
stocks in the same place
go to ftx us download it now here's why
it's interesting though there's other
places you can go and they all say oh we
got no fees we got no fees we got no
fees but on the back end
they got you they're doing payment for
order flow means you don't get best
pricing they're letting people front run
you that ain't real nice
ftx us
they say no fees on the stocks and
no payment for order flow they say look
we're just gonna help you get the best
in the world go get stocks go get
bitcoin go get cryptocurrencies all ftx
us go check them out click on the link
in the description all right what do you
got for us there ms polina oh hey hello
hello
we got the timer we know where we're
looking today
we started our day off hold on i just
want to i want to publicly just say that
i love my wife because uh planet and i
started our day off today in a
government office we had to go to uh a
government office that uh as you all
already know bureaucratic inefficient we
saw a security guard yell at somebody
kick them out of the off i mean it was
wild there was chaos this morning
playing and navigated it perfectly
showed up we had all of our little
documents we haven't made copies for
them so they wouldn't have to have
copies she was all over all right but
still do you know what time are you
looking at anthony
i almost forgot that you were annoying
and now go ahead small business what do
you got for us small businesses are
losing confidence in the u.s economy
they are flashing warning signs on the
u.s economy is inflation supply chains
snarls a shortage of workers and raising
rising interest rates darken the outlook
for entrepreneurs 57 of small business
owners expect economic conditions in the
us to worsen in the next year up from 42
in
april small businesses in america make
up 50 of the jobs this is this is my
whole take on this
the small business entrepreneur
understands the economy better than all
the idiotic economists all the academics
etc i would go and i would talk to
people who own local restaurants who own
local stores et cetera i said what's
going on
and they all would say the same thing
they're like you're it's a joke that
they think inflation's five percent last
summer they're like literally i'll show
you the increasing cost of my business
it's 10 12 14
and so here's the the thing that i want
to get through everyone
while small business owners are saying
oh this is bad this is worse than
they're telling you this is going to get
even worse than it already is right now
we need small business owners that's not
i was looking at the chats we need small
business owners
to help us get out of this they have to
help us build our way out of this we
have 130 debt to gdp in america right
now there's two ways you can do that you
can either stop taking on debt then
you're gonna do that so the next best
thing is we gotta build our way out we
gotta grow our way out of it and small
business owners regardless of what
people think they are the backbone of
america and so we need these people to
say let me pull up my pants
we gotta go to work get the street belt
on
nah you know you you need both hands if
you're doing work you can't be having
street belts really hard because like
what are small businesses supposed to do
in the face of rising inflation i mean
like build build build build
they need literally
build and the hardest part for them
right now is actually not the inflation
the inflation they're gonna try their
best they're gonna pass it on to the
consumer the hardest part is actually i
i believe the employment they're having
a hard time finding people to come work
for them and because they're having a
hard time finding people to come work
for them they end up being understaffed
while still trying to build in this
environment and so that's the difficulty
right now is you have three and a half
percent unemployment you know ballpark
but you have 11 million open jobs in
america and so you're seeing people say
hey i used to pay you for 12 an hour
then 14. then 15. then 16. now i'm at 18
i still can't get anyone to come work
here what am i supposed to do and so
that's where small business
entrepreneurs they got to say to
themselves hey how can i start to build
my business modernize it digitize it
start using technology to fulfill some
of this stuff uh because at the end of
the day if you can't get somebody to
come work there and do the work you've
got to find another solution i feel
really bad for small business owners
especially in places like new york city
i mean we saw so many people
lose um
their livelihood because of everything
that happened
no just call it what it is the
government forced everyone to go sit in
their homes and now we're sitting here
two years later like damn that probably
wasn't smart well you know yeah
um hindsight bias uh but somebody else
hindsight bias if i was saying it at the
time somebody in the comments said
paulina going hard with that printer yes
i did
that's where i printed that's
that's where i i scanned she's a printer
now oh my god
it's truly yeah anyway the best thing
that's ever happened to me okay
so
come on amazon amazon so amazon saw boom
obviously during the pandemic
people were ordering everything so now
um it kind of like it amazon went over
the top and had a ton of warehouse space
now it's looking to shed some of that
excess capacity to sublet this is a
story across the economy is tons of
people ordered too much inventory now
they're sitting with it they're at their
business they went and they expanded a
bunch now they're sitting there with a
bunch of extra space like every single
business from amazon walmart the whole
nine yards everyone is experiencing this
and so it's one smart for amazon to
sublet it sublet is a key word there
because they're not gonna sell it they
know that they'll eventually grow into
the space right they continue to expand
but in the meantime rather than have
them have static unused unmonetized
space on their books what if we could
actually allow somebody else to go ahead
and use it for a little bit period of
time and we'll get some revenue from it
and then we'll go and we'll eventually
grow into that over uh you know in the
future it is crazy because like i order
a lot you would think they need that
extra warehouse oh i know
okay
um so davos is going on do you want to
tell us what davos is for those of us
who don't know i have no comment come on
tell them to tell us it's a collection
of interesting folks who come together
and they talk about interesting ideas
i'm in a good mood today i don't i don't
need to be going anywhere the point is
that davos it's in switzerland right now
and uh
there's there's a ton of they're
offering happy bitcoin pizza day there's
bitcoin pizza stalls a liquidity law
lounge and other treats for the crypto
crowd here's my thing about davos is
there's a certain type of person that
goes there and i actually am gonna i'm
gonna break from i think the the
mainstream talking points i actually
think some good things do come from
davos but on a
over generalization or on a wide scale
there is uh a ton of hypocrisy which i
think is what actually really irritates
people is look rich people meet up all
the time whatever who cares right like
look if they're happy knock yourselves
out whatever you ain't bothering me
but
the problem ends up being that you can't
fly on your private jet to davos to talk
about climate change like
nobody believes you
and so that ends up being i think the
bigger issue is it's less about rich
people getting together like whatever i
think it's the hypocrisy that just
absolutely easy
this is not the topic the topic is i'm
just saying there's a lot of crypto
interest and appetite for crypto pizza
and lounging in the liquidity lounge i
think that there's probably a lot of
like i like blockchain not bitcoin going
on there uh yeah for sure i've seen some
of the videos online and uh that's an
interesting take uh i hope people well
with that uh strategy but that's my
guess uh is that there's a lot of that
going on more so than you know bitcoin i
think davos things like java sometimes
like there's companies and entrepreneurs
that are invited to it that's right it's
really good for them
etc this is my whole thing
i do if somebody said to me educate the
rich if somebody said to me hey i went
to davos i don't judge them like i don't
i don't understand why everyone has uh
this like negative opinion about like oh
you went somewhere
right it's kind of like um
uh for example uh a lot of times when
professional sports teams when they win
a championship they get invited to the
white house
and there's always somebody who's like
nobody on the team should go nobody on
team should go regardless of who's in
office right republican or democrat and
my whole thing is like look
somebody going after they've worked
their whole life to be able to get into
a position of success doesn't mean that
they necessarily agree with everything
that that president regardless of which
side of the aisle believes same thing is
if somebody goes and attends davos that
doesn't mean they agree with everything
actually what's a crazy idea is imagine
if let's say a bitcoiner went to davos
and gave a presentation about bitcoin
and explained this is why bitcoin is
going to potentially change the world
like whether we like it or not we need
somebody i'm not going to do it but
somebody else needs to do it right to go
into that and talk to that crowd of
people and so by the way i just as much
as everyone else thinks there's a ton of
hypocrisy going on there right and well
also i think that there's a lot of
people who frankly not just in the
climate world but if you go down the
line of all this stuff they simply just
look out and they have some
communications person or some pr person
say them okay here's the talking point
you need to make sure that we uh we want
to be socially responsible we want to be
this we want to be this we want to be
this and then you start talking to him
and you're like you literally have no
clue any of the details of this yeah no
i know
sorry i didn't mean to put you in a
position to listen to my davos rant well
it might continue because the next topic
we're talking about is
an additional 573 people have claimed
billionaire status since the covet 19
pandemic began
meanwhile 263 million people are at risk
of falling into extreme poverty this
year i need to see how they define
extreme poverty is this only in the u.s
i'm so confused okay but anyway the
widening of the gap between the rich and
the poor has led to renewed calls for
the us to tax tax wealth and all these
proposals are coming to light during
davos uh a bunch of people at davos are
saying tax me tax me i'm rich
i don't want to hear any of this uh
wealth tax stuff why not because they're
always talking about a wealth tax being
like tax unrealized gains so when all
the asset prices were going up people
were like oh look at those rich people
tax the rich people tax rich people taxi
unrealized gains explain what unrealized
game unrealized gains means if i buy a
stock at 100 and it goes to five hundred
dollars that means there's four hundred
dollars of profit but i haven't realized
yet i haven't sold the stock so i don't
actually have the four hundred dollars
of profit i just have 500 worth of stock
there's a thought process some people
are pushing that they want to tax the
400 gain which would force you to sell
some of the stock in order to then pay
the tax bill which if you're just
sitting there like rich people are
idiots right that sounds great until i
say okay every single american that has
a home
now after your house just went up twenty
percent you owe
tax on the twenty percent gain on your
literally on your own would it affect
that or would it only affect maybe they
would create some carve outs like i
don't know how exactly they would try to
do this but here's the problem now
there's an articles that are coming out
that the billionaires lost a trillion
dollars since the market started to
crash
i don't hear nobody talking about oh the
billionaires should get to write off the
unrealized losses so if you were holding
that stock at 500 and now it's crashed
back to 100 that means you lost 400
so do you get to claim the unrealized
loss
you can't say oh it only works on the
upside but not on the downside see what
i'm saying and so what ends up occurring
again is like rich people almost
categorically not everyone but almost
categorically they're problem solvers
jeff bezos has a great uh uh video clip
that's been circulating where he says i
built a trillion dollar company i made
160 billion myself i'm the founder i
made 160 billion that means i made 840
billion dollars of economic value for
other people now again some people may
argue hey that's too much money that's
not enough money all these different
things right but at the end of the day
what i think ends up being uh incredibly
important here is that a wealth tax
discourages success and if we discourage
success that's a big problem in society
there you go
all right pay phone all right
uh i don't know why this made me so
unbelievably sad but new york city
removed its last public pay phone from
the city on monday
do we have like sad music
why does this make you sad okay oh my
god i'm so sad i think that they
should've done a long time ago walking
past them in new york they're not a
sightseeing they are working
no they're literally there to help
people make phone calls no it reminds me
of the good ol why couldn't they just
leave it there you were in bulgaria as
like a three-year-old when people
actually used these no
have you ever used a pay phone in new
york city like where you put courses in
new york no okay but i enjoyed looking
at them okay and then go to a museum and
then when you walk past them it's all
like you know all nostalgic
why do you think what's going on with
the ask much money
you just sign music
wait i want sad music come on what's the
ask one ah
come on you hear it
oh
i see that's why i don't hear
so
in in the chat i asked people to ask us
a question because there are no
questions guys we should just cut that
segment should we cut it i have a
question for you what do you have
if uh
if you had a pick
if you had to pick
one
animal to have as a pet then most people
wouldn't consider a pet what would you
pick a dolphin
a dog that's a good answer actually in
the bathtub in the bathtub yeah you
could have a dolphin you know what i
would pick
a dinosaur
that actually that's exactly what i
would think yeah but they don't they're
not here with us today
i'm looking at one right now
i love mine all right friends yes i am
from bulgaria whoever asked all right
thank you very much i appreciate it you
and your dolphin be kind to your friends
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time